la rivière romaine sur la contente une
des dernières rivières sauvages au
québec
hydro québec est en train de la hardt
lâcher
c'est le plus gros chantier au pays des
fois raisin touchés sont à déboiser pour
créer les réservoirs
c'est un peu comme du cognac c'est à
dire que ce sont des armes qui ont
poussé très très lent et se donnent des
propriétés physiques qui permettent de
faire des produits de très haut de gamme
nous avons découvert qu hydro québec à
payer deux fois plus cher que la moyenne
pour déboiser le réservoir de romaine 2
un contrat de plusieurs millions $ à
même les deniers publics
véritable cadeau qui n'a pas profité aux
ennemis mais plutôt un sujet antonin
dustrit forestière aujourd'hui la
dernière série de la région est fermée
au siège du bois de chauffage
depuis des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers de mètres cubes de bois
s'accumulent sur le bord de la route qui
mène aux chantiers abandonnés
de quoi remplir 1500 camions remorques
il pourrait lever de votre chauffage
lorsqu'on pose la question
allez donc le but pour avoir du bois de
chauffage de la région ils nous disent
que c'est trop compliqué du bois de
valeur marchande coupé à grands frais
comment expliquer ce gaspillage simple
de le dire y'a matière
nous sommes en pleine nitassinan le
territoire ancestral guérini pour lancer
le projet qui va bouleverser leur
territoire à jamais hydro-québec a
l'obligation de s'entendre avec les
autochtones
la première nation hinault natashquan
voit dans ce projet une opportunité
formidable de bâtir un avenir meilleur
pour ses enfants
natashquan en août à kuan comme disent
les innu pour différencier leurs
communautés de celle de gilles vigneault
hier encore des chasseurs nomades
aujourd'hui mille personnes tentent de
se faire une nouvelle vie le chômage est
endémique les besoins immenses en 2008
les innu de utah quan sont les premiers
à signer une entente avec hydro-québec
qui s'engagent à leur donner 60 millions
de dollars un contrat au minimum
les aînés ont misé sur le déboisement du
futur réservoirs hydroélectriques pour
leur apporter la richesse
mais là on est quand même pas mal à
l'est de sept-îles oui il ya vraiment du
mois avec p dubois du voyage c'est
surtout de l'épinette y compris va
prendre un tiers de sapins deux tiers
des pinottes jean françois côté a fait
l'évaluation pour hydro-québec du bois à
couper ou chantier la romaine
ce sont des terres publiques que le
gouvernement interdit dans noyer sans
avoir récolté les arbres de valeur
marchande forêt qui est parvenu à large
majorité le cube outillés à marcher
cette forêt comme ingénieur forestier
l'idée c'est de faire de la place pour
permettre un aménagement hydroélectrique
alors c'est pas une entreprise
forestière conventionnel hydro québec
donne le contrat de gré à gré apf y une
coentreprise détenue avec rémabec un
géant de l'industrie forestière est une
pratique qu'on a avec les unis dans la
perspective du développement de les
faire profiter de ses deux installations
d'hydro-québec de barrage de structures
etc
donc si ça m'était rémabec vous auriez
peut donner un contrat de gré à gré ce
que c'est parce que c'est avec les i
know exact
même s'il s'agit d'argent public et nous
a fallu près de deux ans de démarches
avec la loi d'accès à l'information pour
obtenir quelques chiffres concernant le
contrat pour romaine 2 le plus gros des
chantiers le contrat de déboisement et
de plus de 34 millions $ 11 1654 à
l'hectare pour récolter les beaux arbres
mais est-ce un prix régulier le coût du
bois ou le coût d'approvisionnement
c'est comme le tabou dans l'industrie
forestière c'est comme demander le
salaire à quelqu'un pour briser ce tabou
nous avons consulté au troisième
ingénieurs lui que le belge justement
spécialisée dans les opérations
forestières
ça revient combien en moyenne au québec
autour d'eux en général 65 60 65 $ du
mètre cube livré aux usa 65 dollars en
moyenne au québec
une étude récente le confirme mais
comment comparer avec le prix à
l'hectare fournis par hydro québec
ce que je vois ici c'est que d'os
selon l'évaluation de la densité de la
forêt le nombre d'arbres à l'hectare le
prix qu'hydro québec a accepté de payer
au mètre cube dans les 216 à 128,1 pas
mal plus cher que 65 dollars la moyenne
au québec donc sur la base de ce calcul
lors vous arrivez au double veux savoir
quelle qu'elles ont été libérés en d2
ces dépenses-là donc parce que dans le
cas d'une exploitation tels qu'on les
imagine cesse ça coûte moins cher
depuis m'arrêter
nous savons que la négociation du
contrat a débuté sur une estimation des
coûts à peine plus élevée que la moyenne
québécoise
même en tenant compte de l'éloignement
et des difficultés du terrain pas le
double vous assurer qu'on est vigilant à
le faire au meilleur coût possible
ça reste un projet très intéressant à
faire avec des coûts des boisements plus
élevé que ce que
l'industriel foresti pourrait faire
l'industriel forestier en plus des coûts
de récoltes fait pour le transport du
bois les chemins et les redevances à
l'état
ici il n'y a pas eu de redevances à
payer nous de frais pour le chemin
principal construit pour le chantier ce
qui réduit d'autant les coûts au final
les québécois ont payé au moins deux
fois plus cher pour déboiser romaine 2
un avantage à profit d'au moins 15
millions $
pourtant i'm outta coin les i nous se
demande où sont passés les profits
depuis la signature de l'entente avec
hydro québec nous thackwell a élu un
nouveau chef
donc j'ai dit là on est en mode aussi de
prendre le contrôle de nos entreprises
une reprise de contrôle car l'ancien
chef avait permis à rémabec de prendre
les décisions au nom de pépé fuit depuis
son siège social à la tuque dans les
communications écrites avec hydro québec
le conseil de bandits nous n'est jamais
en copie
le réveil est brutal une véritable
gueule de bois
il n'y a pas d'argent dans les coffres
est-ce qu'on retrouve des revenus de m
avec non mangeant les pages le comptable
dei nous a mis un an à rapatrier les
bilans financiers du partenariat pf i
j'ai pas vu le groupe rémabec jeu
produit j'ai pas vu de retombées de
produits fort aussi nous
j'ai pas vu de retombées de ces rivières
saint jean mais par contre j'ai vu des
camions se promener sur la route fixée
sur le beau et aller quelque part
ce qui m'a surpris dans les choses que
j'ai vues de rem a b c que il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises liées fait c'est
facile de couper le bois faire affaire
avec leur compagnie qui fournit des
équipements location d'équipement gros
honoraires de gestion
il ya des opérations mystérieuse la pia
à prendre quasiment doctorow pouvoir
aller chercher la vérité que sur le
contenu des partenariats puis et ceux-là
un sens ça des incidences lavenère la
communauté et nous dans nos tâches quoi
le contrat a été signé avec pfj la
coentreprise humour et mabec mais lors
de la négociation rémabec avait le gros
bout du bâton
son grand patron nous a rencontrés avec
un titre vice président et son directeur
des communications
on avait déjà fait de la file avec un
terrible encore avec hydro québec et
hydro québec a intéressé nous avoir
aussi là qu'on avait eu un téléphone
d'hydro-québec et une demande au dessus
de natashquan
il nous apprend que le groupe rémabec à
d'abord négocié sa part du contrat avec
hydro québec
c'est un contrôle une gré à gré mais
nous ce qu'on fait c'est quand on dit si
c'était fait complètement par des
montres hagbe des gens qui ont des
expériences là dedans c'est un contrôle
qui est fait complètement par une
entreprise qui ou ce que tu as des gens
habitués avec beaucoup d'expérience
on négocie et en finale quand on a eu
fini avec hydro-québec on ne dissocie la
portion dans notre langage c'est la
portion blanche et ça a été conviée sur
la portion blanc la sorcière blanche
c'est un contre deux hauts de leur temps
s'ils 27 ou 28 millions et pourtant
hydro québec dit qu'ils ont versé 34
millions de dollars après ça quand on a
eu fini lomé gens se sont retirés
l'homme mois avec les gens du doigt de
tâches one on ne négocie avec hydro
québec ce qui était la portion la
portion formation main d'oeuvre
administration profil de risque qu'ils
donnèrent au delà de 6 millions de
dollars une sorte de dédommagement pour
devoir travailler avec les i nous quand
ils nous disent qu'à pas d'argent qui
rentrait dans les coffres de la
communauté avec ce contrat là de
déboisement est ce que c'est vrai suivra
n'y a pas d'argent qui rentre et nike
offre 10 hinault après dans un bilan de
la collision
les et nous ont mis fin à leur alliance
avec rémabec depuis hydro québec est
pris avec des milliers de mètres cubes
de bois à vendre
voici ce que peu de gens peuvent boire
ni les lits milliers de mètres cubes de
bois qui se dégrade
à plus de 100 km au nord de l'embouchure
de la rivière romaine
de quoi remplir 1500 camions remorques
du loi qui normalement aurait dû aller à
la scierie de rivière saint-jean notre
coentreprise détenue de rim avec une
vieille syrie remise en état de temps du
chantier qu'il ya eu une organisation
c'est pas la communauté qui narre
bénéficier
nous allons la visiter avec joël malek
un mini de nout à cuenca étudie en génie
forestier
la syrie a fermé de façon abrupte
il y a deux ans c'est du bon qui a
trouvé des intempéries depuis même au
sillage de ce pub on se veut un hommage
aux bons pour enfin du bois de chauffage
lorsque les nouveaux élus de nauta coin
n'ont mis fin au partenariat rémabec a
sorti son équipement de cuisine ce qui
en reste quand je te dis c'est la
squelette et puis là le coeur est plus
le cas les pontes d'auteuil est plus
long depuis le silence règne
l'isie nous ont perdu l'argent investi
pendant quatre ans la série a été
alimentée par le bois coupé à la romaine
hydro-québec le vendaient à un prix
défiant toute concurrence
10 dollars le mètre cube transport payer
c'est une fraction du prix régulier
c'est une manne parce que normalement ça
devrait coûter pas mal plus cher que le
zen dans sa cour et reçoit mètres cubes
de bois commercial d'idr n'avait pas
l'air de vouloir cross est un peu à
générac et engageait du bois en usine
vous ouvrez l'oeil du bois qui apparaît
prêt à être transformée dans ma cour du
sinn
ben je vais être content si je peux la
voir à 50,70 dollars livre les usines
en vendant à ce prix hydro québec donne
un net avantage à l'acier mais c'est une
perte d'au moins 10 millions de dollars
pour les contribuables
au niveau de la vente ce qu'on a fait
c'est des ententes avec les i nous pour
s'assurer que il pouvait attirer avoir
un certain bénéfice ou six dessins même
si on payait pour le brochet étant
donnée la gros la capacité l'usm d'alger
et aussi qu'il fallait pour mai du
nouveau roman en deux facteurs comme
étant une grande fête avec l'afrique et
ce déficit a été épongée avec les
profits réalisés au déboisement
d'abord pf qui a payé la filiale de
rayman est très bon les baies avec un
taux fixe est habitué qu'il est habitué
des coupes et du bourg en eau l'équipe
mais on a tout ce qu'il faut couper du
bois à une vitesse assez surprenant
venant ni renommée dans la province
mais on avait mis au clair ou tout début
le contrôle 1,7 à ce prix dont ceux qui
restent c'est la somme prévue pour
l'usiné de la maintenir 25 qui nous a la
droit ok face à toutes les dépenses qui
connexes aso
comme il n'y a pas eu le nombre entendu
de travailleurs et nous hydro québec a
retenu une partie de la somme destinée à
leur formation
le reste 2 millions $ a été engloutie
dans le difficile cap adare gens qui
rentraient dans les coffres désigne la
pologne à cause de la série god
l'affairé du contrat de déboisement qui
devait leur apporter la richesse les et
nous ont eu que leur salaire d'ouvrier
il y a eu moins de travailleurs que
prévu le groupe rémabec lui a eu accès à
une nouvelle forêt uniquement parce
qu'il était associé avec les innu les
beaux arbres trop gros pour la scierie
de rivière saint-jean rémabec a pu les
garder pour une autre de ses filiales
harbec à port cartier
aujourd'hui le déboisement se poursuivre
ce chantier la romaine sans rémabec les
et nous se sont trouvé un autre
partenaire mais comme il n'y a plus de
syrie les bio s'accumulent depuis trois
ans en attendant qu'hydro-québec trouve
une destination à son bois
en main gagny les résidents m d'habiller
chauffer leur maison avec ce bois plutôt
que de les laisser croupir sur les bords
du scion le rien ne bouge et on se
demande d'où aussi le fait ce qu'ils
vont faire exploser
est-ce qu'il va pourrir là où il va
servir à d'autres choses on ne sait pas
parce qu'on pourrait l'étudier du bois
de chauffage
la réponse au québec sinon on pourrait
décider unilatéralement de le lan
disposer mais ce qu'on souhaiterait
faire c'est de le faire en collaboration
avec nos partenaires et nous mais il
semble avoir une dispute entre les noms
et leurs partenaires à eux
hydro québec est pris entre l'arbre et
les corses c'est son bois mais la syrie
la plus proche appartient au groupe
rémabec si vous attendez que les ignorer
rémabec s'entendre ça peut prendre un
certain temps
oui il ya comme je le disais il ya une
limite qu'on va atteindre bientôt parce
qu'on laissera pas le bourg
le broc pourrir l'on va devoir procéder
une fois que le poids
il y aura du désuet pour le sillage
après ça il y est bon pour la biomasse
ce à quoi je vais le mal est fait
allusion la biomasse ce sont des résidus
du bois comme ceux qui vont alimenter
les deux futures usines liées au groupe
rémabec ça fait plaisir au nom du
gouvernement du québec d'y apporter sa
contribution d'un prêt de 30 millions de
dollars
elles viennent d'obtenir de l'aide
financière des gouvernements 76 million
et demi de dollars en tout à
port-cartier sur la côte-nord 3 millions
l usine de parents en haute mauricie
le ministre lessard est sous enquête par
le commissaire à l'éthique pour avoir
accordé cette subvention car le nouvel
associé de rémabec et yvon nadeau
l'ancien conseiller de longue date du
ministre alors responsable de la forêt
le patron de remake semble faire flèche
de tout bois
marie-eve bédard de la garde rapprochée
des libéraux pendant huit ans a agi
comme lobbyiste pour obtenir le
financement à port cartier
le directeur des communications de
rémabec pierre-olivier lussier était
l'attachée de presse du ministre da fort
et son passage rapide chez rémabec
violent les règles déontologiques a
soulevé l'opposition en avant 2015
l'attachée de presse du ministre des
forêts au tlm in-stat des forêts pour
aller immédiatement chez rim avait une
grosse entreprise qui oeuvre dans le
secteur de la forêt et sans plus tarder
et j'inviterai le premier ministre et
député de roberval monsieur philippe
couillard avenue c'est lui qui donne ici
la parole à philippe couillard pour
annoncer des subventions et l'ex sous
ministre adjoint à la forêt jean sylvain
lebel un an plus tard il s'inscrit comme
lobbyiste pour le groupe rémabec
alors que tout va rondement pour emma
bec
les amoureux ont dû barrer la route du
chantier pour attirer l'attention sur
leur sort mais autochtone et c'est très
bien ainsi veulent négocier avec nous
d'égal à égal donc on a négocié des
contrats avec eux et ensuite on peut pas
aller par dessus leur épaule voix ans
ils font de bonne entente des
communautés autochtones comme celle de
natashquan
ça fait pas vingt et un ans qui sont en
affaires c'est récent ok ski france aux
kurdes a vraiment ils ont manqué
d'encadrement autant l'encadrement de
caisse qui se posent à sociétés
apparentées autant divulguer
l'information comment les i nous ont
travaillé avec rémabec pour fonder payer
fille comme elle se sont partagés le
partenariat les pourcentages de revenus
de profits l'organisation de rugby à
saint jean on n'est pas de ce côté là
donc on n'a pas voulu s'immiscer la
danse notamment d'autres sims et lada
le bois coupé sous les lignes
électriques ou s'y est laissé en plan
ici des résidents viennent se servir en
catimini dans le bois abandonné à la
suite de la faillite d'un sous-traitant
d'hydro-québec tout ce gaspillage de
bois choc les résidents qui vont bûcher
pour se chauffer mais les feuillus comme
le bouleau ou le tram sont les ont
brûlés sur place certains crimes pour
les autres un peu près de moisi on vous
prête c'est celle on n'a pas beaucoup de
boulot puis senna seul bois de chauffage
durant guillemets
il n'y a pas de syrie pour recevoir les
feuillus ils ont été soit laissé sur
place et en noyer comme ici dans le
réservoir de romaine 2 ou bully
hydro québec aurait pu facilement mettre
sur le bord du chemin pinault pour qu'on
s'en serve comme bois de chauffage à la
limite et pendant moyens de s'y rendre
hydro-québec a détruit le chemin quand
on voit la route pour n'y a pas que
c'est sûr on peut aller lors à pied ou
en 4 ou mais on peut pas aller loin avec
nous ramène à notre peuple le sait c'est
certes on a notre calvaire qui est parti
puis si c'est une job de savage pareil
parce que quand on regarde seuls sont
venus ici et ont pris une pelle on a
enlevé à peu près le tuyau ils ont mis
la gauche de côté puis c'est fini nous
laissons humanité ces mêmes qui payent
en fait soit par tous
hydro-québec affirme que c'est le
gouvernement qui l'a obligé à agir ainsi
aidé au québec parce qu'en même temps il
vaut québec on s'en aperçoit tout est
fait tout est fini
pour hydro québec le déboisement est
accessoire la petite monnaie dans les
milliards de dollars consacrés au projet
de la romaine mais pour lézignan qui
comptais là-dessus pour améliorer leur
sort c'est un lendemain de veille
difficile est en train de se battre avec
hydro québec pour dire vous nous avez
promis ça est-ce que sébastien de ce qui
reste du projet de lf ac comme que nous
l'avait présentée dans vous étude
environnementale puisque que tout le
monde soit satisfait l'autre je pense
que hydro-québec bernie plus qu'une
personne dans toutes ces histoires là il
ya eu des énergies qui ont été investi
là-dedans par le conseil des
déplacements des rencontres
mais ce héros va tomber ces luttes à
quoi nous serons plus pauvres du design
de la romaine qu'ils étaient à 20 ben
c'est certain que ça va être un dossier
explosif pour être comme une auto lock
c'est votre problème pour eux
j'avais un problème pour nous dans la
région
où
je